another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do with the foundation dr  bright must be reminded that the better  business bureau is not the correct  agency for dealing with containment  failures from horrible eldritch  artifacts sold by marshall carter and  dark marshall carter and dark exist at  the frightening intersection of dark  anomalous power and unfettered  capitalism they're one of the most  powerful groups of interest out there  with almost unlimited funds and an  utterly ruthless desire to profit at all  costs the better business bureau are  utterly toothless against a group of  their sheer unrelenting power they can  grease any palm and snap any neck the  poor lowly bbb would not be able to land  a hit on them the irs on the other hand  is a completely different story